bonsoir messieurs bienvenue sur rt
france à leur première question cette
sortie polémique de gérald darmanin a
beaucoup fait parler est ce qu'il s'agit
selon vous d'un dérapage ou bien d'une
communication voulue et assumée
arnaud benedetti en bois ya trois
lectures la première lecture c'est de
considérer qu' il y à un vent de panique
c'est à dire qu' un certain nombre de
sondages depuis maintenant plusieurs
jours montrent que les listes du
rassemblement national arrive en tête
dans plusieurs régions avec pour
certaines de ces régions une possibilité
de l'emporter au second tour et que
ignorer ce point de vue là par ned et
cultive tout d'un coup une crainte de
voir ce ce résultat à devenir la
deuxième lecture c'est une lecture que
je le qualifierais de plus machiavélique
ou de plus cynique c'est de considérer
qu' il s'agit là encore une fois de
continuer à planter le décor entre deux
ans entre 1 affronte dans un
affrontement entre deux marques entre
deux offres politiques celle représentée
par emmanuel macron et celle représentée
par le rassemblement national pour de la
sorte exclure toute autre hypothèse que
cette scène politique
troisième lecture c'est une lecture qui
peut être traduit la difficulté
je pense aussi de l'exécutif et d'une
partie d'ailleurs de la classe politique
à relire aujourd'hui ce qu'est le
rassemblement national
c'est à dire qu'on continue à penser
finalement le rassemblement national
comme l'était dans les années 80 où dans
les années 90 c'est à dire dirigé par
jean-marie le pen 120 intégré le fait
qu'il s'agit d'une formation politique
qui s'est transformée
c'est d'une certaine manière
dédiaboliser s'est banalisé et qu' il y
a vraisemblablement peut-être la volonté
face à cette diabolisation de re
diaboliser d'essayer de rhodia bolide
de réactiver le processus de
diabolisation mais je ne suis pas sûr
que ça soit très opérationnelle à
quelques jours du premier tour d'une
élection régionale et départementale
justement stéphane rozès vous estimez
normal que le ministre de l'intérieur en
terre faire de la sorte dans cette
campagne des élections régionales
disons que c'est habituel effectivement
la majorité mène des batailles des
ministres sont envoyés effectivement les
enjeux sont lourds je suis d'accord avec
arnaud benedetti d'une part des
intentions de vote montre la pression le
rassemblement national dans un certain
nombre de régions et d'autre part la
république en marche a pris l'initiative
de proposer des fusions de listes ce qui
est temps qu'à l'issue du premier tour
face au front national
ce qui au fond ne mange pas trop de pain
pour lui parce idée n'est jamais en
première ligne a donc qui apparaît comme
celui qui défend en premier lieu la
république
et puis ça nous permet de continuer à
semer la zizanie à droite on pense
évidemment à la situation de son plus
grand rival pour l'heure de la majorité
au mime à une peine saddier bertrand
dans les hauts de france passe
effectivement il ya une cohérence
emmanuel macron va souhaiter que rien
n'existe entre lui et le rassemblement
national
bonnart initié de façon je dirais très
très extrême avec d'ailleurs toutes les
limites indique arnaud benedetti à
l'égard desquels je suis d'accord marine
le pen notamment d'eric de pied
dernières européennes a réussi à faire
opérer une mutation du nationalisme à la
nation d'une formation d'extrême droite
a une formation l'île devient très beau
diène elle perd elle peine à renouveler
néanmoins s'est cabré peine à ce trait
d'immuniser sur sa capacité
l'arrêt jure en cas de victoire à
majorité me claire mois nous mener 2-1
pour les français eux-mêmes pour nouveau
mythologue ce qu'est le rassemblement
national en tout cas moi ça ne fait pas
mal de temps que je le dis je ne définis
le rassemblement national comme une
formation d'extrême droite si vous me le
permettez puisqu'il s'agit de monsieur
d'arman on en parlait avec arnaud
benedetti l'avant il ya une équation
particulière darmana parce que il n'ya
de subir un camouflet de la part du
conseil d'état sur un certain nombre de
dispositions sur son schéma de maintien
de l'ordre sur manifesté une
interdiction des nas le fait que les
journalistes ne puisse plus couvrir les
fans manifestation donc dit ses prix
après avoir manifestement côté des
petits clones tchèque quand même un
camouflet de la part du conseil d'état
et on en parlait avec arnaud benedetti
date de talent autrefois de nicolas
sarkozy de jouer de mouvements de sorte
qu'on parle de ce propos exagérés on ne
parle pas on ne parle pas de ce
camouflet du conseil d'état puis une
seconde chose c'est que je termine lors
du dernier débat avec marine le pen
il avait semblé dire que elle était un
peu molle sur un certain nombre de
choses c'était pas très en cohérence
avec la stratégie présidentielle
d'emmanuel matheron est donc là il fait
une opération de rattrapage événements
et suivez moi allons savoir stéphane
rozès vous l'avez dit gérald darmanin a
essuyé une salve de critiques de
nombreux revers notamment le sujet
son schéma du maintien de l'ordre vous
pensez-vous arnaud benedetti qu malgré
tout que cette sortie du patron de la
place beauvau elle peut avoir un
quelconque impact sur ces élections
régionales n'ont vraisemblablement non
ce n'est pas avoir un impact et
éventuellement de mobiliser
en plus l'électorat du rassemblement
national parce que plus vous diaboliser
une marque politique
il y à une partie des électeurs et des
électrices du rassemblement national
qu'ils peuvent
disons le vivre aussi comme une
diabolisation personnel de leur
orientation électorale donc je crains
que en effet la la la la la la la
controverse que suscite aujourd'hui les
ministres de l'intérieur par ces propos
et pour effet principal d'accroître
éventuellement la dynamite sur le
terrain du rassemblement national en
tout cas c'est une hypothèse
moi je pense que si vous voulez ya
plusieurs contradictions dans les propos
de monsieur darmana il ya une première
contradiction c'est celle qu'a rappelé
très justement stéphane rozès c'est le
fait que lors de son débat avec marine
le pen
il avait donné le sentiment d'être
parfois plus radicale dans ses positions
que la présidente du rassemblement
national donc là il en revient à une
interprétation du rassemblement national
qui est plus conforme en effet à celle
du logiciel macro nist l'admets mais il
ya une autre contradiction il ya une
contradiction cela même de l'exécutif il
ya quelques jours on a vu le ministre
des l'économie considérait que le
rassemblement national il le dire avec
d'ailleurs une forme de mépris
l'arrogance que c'était une petite chose
alors si vous voulez on peut pas à la
fois considérer que l'adversaire est une
petite chose mais en même temps
considéré qu' il a une dimension d'ordre
satanique il ya là aussi une
contre-allée une contradiction il ya une
troisième contradiction dans le contexte
dans lequel que que nous que nous
traversons on voit bien que il y à un
appel quand même d'un certain nombre de
responsables politiques à 10 ont
esquissé quand même une baisse de
tension dans le débat public
les mêmes d'ailleurs le président de la
république s'efforce de considérer qu'il
faut apporter plus de rationalité dans
le débat fasse un écosystème qui
aujourd'hui tu en as series et moi je
pense que les propos de gérald darmanin
il participe de fait de l'hystérisation
du débat public parce que en
l'occurrence il
il normal son concurrent politique il le
stigmatise d'une telle manière que cela
apparaît excessif y compris à ceux qui
sont les adversaires les plus résolus du
rassemblement national et par cette
communication dont encore une fois on
peut s'interroger sur les intentions
eh ben il tend tout simplement à
apporter sa pierre à l'hystérisation du
débat public
cela à une semaine d'une élection
départementale et d'une élection
élections régionales
je ne suis pas sûr encore une fois que
ça soit le meilleur moyen de s'opposer
au rassemblement national et à la
pression qu'exerce le rassemblement va
seul al sur le terrain aujourd'hui au
niveau régional mais aussi parfois au
niveau départemental stéphane rozès vous
disiez tous les deux un que le parti est
bien s'était transformée au fil des
années qu'ils s'étaient dédiaboliser et
pourtant il ya une marche demain contre
l extrême droite apparaît ça veut dire
qu'il ne s'est pas aussi bien
dédiaboliser que ça ce parti oui vous
avez raison de rafler cette marche
importante pour une partie de la gauche
puisque elle défile sur l'idée de l'idée
de lutter contre les idées d'extrême
droite qu'elle ne réserve pas seulement
au rassemblement national par rapport à
notre débat immédiat mais qu'elle
réserve aux fonds et à une sorte de
dérive ce noël de la majorité de ma
chronique du pays et même une partie de
la gauche la gauche républicaine par
exemple je voudrais insister sur cela
dit arnaud meneghetti en cohérence avec
la mutation opérée par marine le pen
vous ne verrez nous allons connaître un
climat de départ de la présidentielle
rude d'augmenter les français vont se
rendaient aux urnes mais dès maintenant
discours du président de l'acro
dis que nous sommes au moyen-âge certes
mais avant la renaissance
ce qui laisse augurer que il pourrait y
avoir des lendemains heureux que xavier
bertrand va voir un discours positif et
vous le verrez marine le pen en discours
positif
elle va se présenter comme celle qui est
là pour apaiser la nation parce qu' elle
ne serait pas la représentante de
minorité de groupes d'intérêt mais
qu'elle défendrait la nation la
république et chacun des français pour
ce qu'il est c'est à dire un citoyen est
donc effective à cassette vous plaît
pour conclure parce que l'interview
touche à sa fin stéphane rozès sa merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue
président de conseils analyses et
perspectives et enseignant à hec
sciences-po merci à vous également
arnaud benedetti est rédacteur en chef
de la revue de politique et
parlementaire